الان هناك على الهواء مباشره يمكن ان تروا
الصواريخ تنطلق من شمال قطاع غزه الان
ثلاثه او اربعه صواريخ رايناها تنطلق اذا
والان هناك صاروخ ياتي باتجاهنا
وصواريخ اخرى ايضا تاتي يعني من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تاتي الصواريخ الى قطاع من قطاع
غزه تجاه مستوطنات الغلاف الان ستحاول
القبه الحديديه الاعتراض لبعض الصواريخ
هذا المشهد يتكرر في الساعتين الاخيرتين
تباعا اكثر من 80 صاروخا اطلقت في خلال
الساعتين الاخيرتين
سفارات الانذار تنطلق في معظم مستوطنات
غلاف غزه الان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات